we all know snake is this absolute  weapon  so i knew i had to step up my game with  kenji  tanigaki we did such an intensive  training course  many movies just have a sword fight it's  a gunfight  car action but this movie have  everything kenji is a myth  a legend a god  he's got years of knowledge of  choreography and swords like samurai  stuff  that sword work is the best i've ever  seen  join us what do i have to do  let's find out first week is hell week  your body  is literally going from zero to 60.  all of the actors they really breathe  these characters through the training  very intense but super fun  kind of like learning how to dance but  you are bruised at the end  it was hard but now i feel invincible  through the training we all realized a  lot about  ourselves we could do every single thing  that was thrown at us  it's pretty amazing actually  [Music]  you